like you have that kind of time for bob
lazar yes
yes
but maybe not for donald trump no that's
different because bob lazar
what what you know what he's talking
about like i wanted to know with the
babazar thing i wanted to know first of
all i want to be around him and see if i
could smell [ __ ] did you like did
okay no i didn't man that was what's
weird about it not only did i not smell
[ __ ] i went over all of his
interviews i went he hasn't done a lot
but he's done enough
and he's done them over the course of
30 plus years and
it's alarming how consistent his story
is which is really weird when you think
about you're talking about back
engineering alien crafts and working on
a
you know a top-secret government test
site that's carved into the side of a
mountain and to camouflage it from
satellites
it's a it's such a wacky story
but the guy really did work at los
alamos labs he really is a propulsions
expert he really is a scientist
um
did he really work on back engineering
ufos i don't know but the way he
described their motion is exactly like
what's been observed by uh some of these
pilots that have these videos that
they've captured and i just love that
like nasa i've been hearing from a bunch
of folks who they're legitimately
like funding research and
there's people really
taking this seriously of um ufo
sightings investigating them yeah like
adding more and more sensors to collect
data from just observing
higher definitions it's it's cool to
finally see that he was one of the early
people whether he's full of [ __ ] or not
that kind of
forced people to start taking this kind
of
these topics seriously or at least
force people to have conversations about
them and maybe attempt to debunk them
because it seems so preposterous but
then get sucked down the rabbit hole and
start going hmm maybe we'll [ __ ] it's
the thing is like the fermi paradox like
where are they right and when you take
into account just the sheer raw numbers
the vast majority of people objectively
assume that there is life out there
the vast majority well if if you really
take into account what we understand
about the universe itself what we
understand about the concept of of
infinity and the way neil degrasse tyson
has explained it to me is that
not only
are there life forms out there but
there's you you are out there infinity
is so large that lex friedman exists and
doesn't just exist but exists an
infinite number of times like the amount
of interactions that cells and molecules
the same exact interactions that have
happened here on earth have happened in
the exact same order
an infinite number of times in the
cosmos well first of all it's not
certain that that's true
it's possible possible uh like sean
carroll you know uh
especially with quantum mechanics
based on certain interpretation of
quantum mechanics that's that's very
possible but the question is can you
access
those universes right and so how far
away are they the more the more sort of
specific practical question is this
local pocket of the universe our galaxy
or our neighboring galaxies are there
aliens there what do they look like are
they so you can have this panspermia
idea where a much larger
like
uh like daddy civilization
uh like uh rolled by and just planted a
few aliens at a similar time like
prometheus yes yeah a different you know
throughout the galaxy and those are the
ones we might be interacting with
they're all
kind of dumb
as we are relatively you know maybe a
few million years apart
and then those are the ones we're
interacting with and then we have a
chance to actually connect with them and
communicate with them or it could be
like
much more wide open and you have these
gigantic alien civilizations that are
expanding very very quickly and the
interesting thing is when you look up at
the sky and you see the stars that's
light
from those stars
we might not be seeing the alien
civilizations until they're already here
meaning
right like you start expanding once you
get really good at expanding you're
going to be expanding very close to the
speed of light so right now we don't see
much in the in the sky but there could
be one one day we wake up and it's just
like everywhere and they're here right
right because the amount of time the
light takes to reach us yeah uh and then
the
the thing that i've been really
fascinated by is these
alternative forms of transportation that
they're discussing like the the ability
to harness wormholes and the the ability
to
to do things that uh
a type three civilization is capable of
i had michio kaku on my podcast recently
fantastic love that guy he's so he's so
good at taking extremely complex
concepts and boiling them down for
digestion
and and you know and saying them in a
way that other people can appreciate and
not being hesitant about saying wild
crazy [ __ ] that's out there but grounded
in what's actually possible yeah he's
all in on this ufo phenomenon now he's
now he's like now the burden of proof is
to people for people to come up with
some sort of a conventional explanation
for these things he goes because these
things are defying all the concepts of
physics that that we're we currently
know in terms of what our capabilities
are and and propulsion systems and and
so many other things that you know what
we know about what current science is
capable of reproducing as far as what we
know the problem is like uh
these um military
projects that are
top secret like how much money do they
have they have a lot of money like but
is it possible and maybe you could speak
to this is it possible that there could
be
some propulsion systems that have been
developed and implemented that are far
beyond just the simple burning of rocket
fuel pushing the fire out the back which
forces the rocket at extreme speeds
forward that's something that does
harness gravity something that can
distort space and time and can make
travel from one point to another uh like
preposterously fast well not only is it
possible i think
it's likely that that kind of stuff
would be
kept a secret yeah it's just everything
you see about these um
about the way
either if it's contractors like lockheed
martin or if it's dod the the the actual
departments of defense they operate in
complete secrecy just even looking at
the
the history of the stealth fighter just
even stealth technology was kept a
secret for a very very long time and
not until you're ready to use it
and need to use it
does it become public and not officially
public it just is being detected out in
the wild so
there's going to be a process where
you're secretly testing it and that
might creep up which is maybe what we're
seeing and then it's waiting for the
next big war
the next big
reason to use the thing yeah and so yeah
this there's definitely technologies now
there might not be propulsion
technologies there could be ai
surveillance technologies that could be
different kinds of
uh stealth drones
there could be uh it could be also in
cyberspace like cyber war
weapons all that kind of stuff that
they're obviously going to be kept
secret
i'm i'm very skeptical lately and the
reason why i'm skeptical is the
government keeps talking about it the
pentagon keeps talking about it nasa
keeps talking about it in which
direction you're skeptical i'm skeptical
that it's their aliens i think most
likely it's a smoke screen and most
likely these are some sort of like
incredibly advanced drones that they've
developed that they
want to pretend don't exist that seems
the more likely scenario because
otherwise
my take is like what's the benefit of
them discussing these things like what's
the benefit of them discussing these
things openly these are you know
what the way they described it off-world
crafts
not made from this earth
like
why why would they why would they tell
us that i mean unless there's an
imminent
danger of us being invaded and they want
to prepare people so they don't freak
out as much
you know like maybe freak them out a
little bit say that publicly the new
york times article the pentagon
discussing it all these different things
that's the waters
yeah well let people know that this is a
thing yeah or
my take is like that i don't think they
do that i don't think they tell us
i think they i think
i think the government has a lot of
contempt for for the citizens i really
do i think they have contempt for our
intelligence they have contempt for our
need to know things and i also think
they think that they are running us it's
not we're all in this together and the
government works for the people and the
government is of the people i don't
think they think that way yeah the the
basic idea is you can't trust the
populist to govern itself because we're
a bunch of idiots
i think that's accurate
well
they're not wrong but they're also
they're also idiots power hunger idiots
yeah i don't think they're i don't think
everyone's an idiot but i think there
are enough idiots that it becomes a real
problem if you're completely honest
about everything you do and you know you
don't want to
let everybody weigh in about things that
are incredibly complex and that most
people are ignorant of
you